I was just down in Antarctica on a
really incredible expedition we're doing
a climate change story on the wildlife
and the conditions and a fishing story
as well on what's happening down in
Antarctica and the last five days of the
journey we crossed the Drake Passage on
a boat this is our little boat here and
the Drake Passage is like notoriously
bad right I had no idea what I was
getting into and I've I feel like I've
traveled a lot in my life but I've never
commuted like this before right the
entire team didn't even know what they
were getting into and you could see the
boat pitches and rolls and and just
navigating around the boat was a
nightmare eating using the bathroom was
this not even worth getting into it was
crazy and by the end of the journey you
know you're so spun that when we finally
go and by the way this is when it was
calm enough where we could actually roll
cameras right so it was the waves we've
got this high as 30 feet the winds were
sighs 60 knots and the best thing you
could do is just like lay in your bed
and just take it right there's enough
there's no way out of it it's like a
mobile prison but but it's an experience
I'm glad that I did because I I've read
all about Shackleton and the original
Antarctica explorers and everything else
and it was great to actually go down and
have that experience right I like the
bitter sweetness of this job and getting
on location I'll be honest that's
generally the biggest adventure is
getting on location so this is kind of a
typical stance for me when I'm shooting
climbing it's hanging like a thousand
feet off the ground on a rope and I've
got my little poles to keep me stable so
I can roll video or take photos or
whatever it is just waiting for the
climbers to come up that was in the vert
on gorge which is here the vert on
gorges in France it's pretty much
considered Europe's Grand Canyon and
it's a place with the rich climbing
history and in 2014 I did a story in a
short film for National Geographic
adventure on the beautiful gorge in its
history and we had so much fun playing
on the big great canyon walls two years
ago I did a great road trip for a
National Geographic travel where I
started up in Montana in the mountains
near Glacier National Park ending all
the way down in the southeast side in
the desert areas and I guess
experience everything in between and
National Geographic you never know what
they're going to throw you right you get
these great calls and they there we got
a great job for you and it's always
exciting last summer I got to Trek from
Switzerland all the way down to the
French Riviera
following the gr5 trail system and I got
to see so many different places in the
Alps I wish I could have stayed there
the entire summer it was unbelievably
beautiful and the assignments you never
know how long they're going to be SAT
had mentioned there was a six-week
assignment on Antarctica and I've
actually think it was 54 days in Blanc
so I think it was even a little longer
than that it was it was 2 months and
this assignment here this was two days
so you never know what you're going to
get it's everything in the middle this
is a really fun project this was about
these people in Colorado that they ice
race they soup up their jeeps they put
spikes on their tires and they ice race
all winter long and I got to make a
short little film on it and here's the
film the minute I put my helmet on strap
in and it's time to hit the gas pedal
there's some sort of switch that just
goes off and it's like total serene
total peace I'm in my own zone and I'm
ready to fly
[Music]
I'm a third-generation ice racer I grew
up with my dad and my grandpa in the
shop racing is definitely my blood
I've loved it not just for the fact I
think that I've been around it but I do
think I was wanted to be here to drive
and build stuff I think everything that
I build so hard it's a piece of me the
different tones and sounds of vision
it's curiosity to me I love it
probably the biggest thing to any race
car is the engine next to the driver
there's this huge sense of
accomplishment when I build something
working on a vehicle especially my own
is extremely therapeutic it's like total
peace there's no other experience
nothing else like it I truly love
building something seeing it come to
shade come to life you give it your own
personal touch and you take that to the
track and then in terms see what your
driving capability can do the town of
your town relies on us to give them a
number reading in the morning before
anybody goes out so we will walk out
physically drill that lake to see where
we're at
it's common to have clubs or
organizations such as the Daytona 500
with NASCAR NHRA and drag racing our
gang that's our club organ generations
after generations have played a huge
part keeping the club going I hope that
it continues to grow and you know our
kids in the next kids in the next kids
complete the cycle competitions always
been fierce at Georgetown but there's
always been competition
pushes me to the next level
when I go to erase my main objective is
to win I know I'm going to go there but
the chance that I might get beat and
that's fine but that's what makes that
risk all that much more important enough
we're not going to get rich off of ice
reason you're going to get rich in
friends and passion and experience but
not money you spend countless hours
building this G to go have seconds of
fun but when you do it completely pays
for itself you forget how many hours
helps or your fingers house or your
hands or how tired you are when you hit
that gas and spend time with your family
you put somebody's smile on our faces
you give a ride to it's breathtaking
thank you I'm glad you like it that was
such a fun job and I thought ice
climbing was barbaric this was crazy
that they can only race on a track for
so long because it just tears it up and
guts it enough to like move over to
another one to kind of keep going and I
got to take a ride in one of the jeeps
you know and they're 900 horsepower so
they're unbelievably burly and fast and
when you you know you had that they held
the craziest seatbelts you had to like
strap in like five different ways in
case that rolled and when that guy was
Jimmy Olsen when he hit the gas it would
like you could pop a wheelie that's
crazy
there was a lot of fun working with you
I've never worked around people that are
like that into cars before so it was
really fun in 2013 I went and did what
was maybe one of the most fun rock
climbing trips I've ever had in my life
it was it was my assignment after
Antarctica and I almost feel like
National Geographic threw me a bone
they're like okay you suffered I can go
have this really fun one I got to go
with three of my really good friends
Matt Siegal see - right and Emily
Harrington they were the climbers and I
got to team up with Carsten Peter who's
an absolute legendary photographer he's
a real hero of mine and Carsten does a
lot of the caves stories you see in the
magazine subterranean work and and his
lighting work is amazing he's really
really diligent artistic person this
picture right here he's actually holding
a drone that just freshly crashed while
he was flying around the big spire on
the left and you know things like that
happen on these trips all the time
but going to these places we went to
these karst formations that were amazing
and what a karst is it's it's a
geological formation it takes you know
millions of years to you know which for
them to form but they're basically they
start like and usually like limestone
mountains and water gets inside of them
and the water acidifies as it sort of
mixes with the limestone and it meets
the caves and caverns into the walls the
water spills out wind comes in and the
next thing you know I have a beautiful
arch where you have a spire and you can
see this like dripping rock they're
actually constantly forming anytime
there's rain the water is it drips down
and acidifies building stalactites all
the time what's the perfect jungle gym
for rock climbing right so this is like
a 600 foot arch this is my friend cedar
and Matt on the wall and I'm going to
show you the short film we made while we
were down there
[Music]
[Music]
traveling to China is really one of the
more unique travel experiences that I've
had it's one of the most diverse
landscapes that I've ever experienced
[Music]
it's like you walk into a painting for
historic landscape these ancient cars
formations have been sculpted by wind
and water and millions of years of
erosion into these beautiful natural
sculptures as a rock climber you look at
these rock formations you can't help but
be inspired for me it's important not
just to go and see these amazing
landscapes but to interact with them to
get to climb on them it's just the
experience of lifetime
the stone here offers up gymnastic
athletic movement but it cost me very
adventurous sometimes dangerous but
always beautiful this is what we love to
do to come beautiful natural areas on
and explore and push ourselves mentally
and physically
[Music]
China is relatively unexplored and you
two climbers into adventurers who want
to go out and see something spectacular
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these limestone karsts are some of the
most beautiful rock formations in the
world you go into a landscape like this
and it affects you and it changes you as
a person and inspires you that's the
climber that's really the biggest part
of it it's something that I'll carry
with me for the rest of my life thank
you that really was such a fun trip I
mean even seeing Emily dancing on the
top of the tower at the end it was a
scoop and often having fun the whole
time and these climbers that's when
they're in their element you know when
they're getting to do this and it was
just a carte blanche canvas it was like
climb that climb that for Carson it was
great for the photos you know this gives
scale to the size of these gigantic
formations and it was great for me as
well from you know from the filmmaking
side and yeah fun so I grew up in
Colorado it's really where I found
adventure you know I was lucky when I
was at the age of two my parents moved
us from New Jersey to Colorado Springs
and it was the ultimate background to
have right I had this fantastic backyard
and we embraced Colorado quite quickly
this is me when I was little kid loved
getting dirty and skinning my knees and
catching snakes and and all things you
know that I anything I could do any
excuse to get out and get dirty I was
all about it and every weekend you know
we would be up in the mountains fishing
and camping and it was just the most fun
place to grow up and I was it became
very passionate about the outdoors the
other thing I was incredibly passionate
about was skateboarding and my brother
got me into skateboarding I have an
older brother he's three years older
than Scott and anything Scott was into I
typically would get into as well so when
he got into skateboarding I naturally
did this well about 18 years old in this
picture here so Scott had already moved
out of the house I had just moved out of
the house and you know we would we'd
talk on the phone all the time which so
meet up go skate and on this particular
day he showed up and he had a camera
with him it wasn't unusual because my
brother's really artistic
and he can draw on pottery paint all
this when he showed up with the camera I
was like that is one more thing that's
cuts into that school and he said hey I
brought a camera today and I thought we
could take turns like taking photos of
each other while we skated you know
we'll go all around the city today and
go to our favorite places I was like
that's great but I don't know how to use
a camera you know he's like no worries
man I'll show you how to do it super
easy and he did and it was real basic he
kind of gave me the basics and sure
enough we took pictures of one another
and I saw him about three days later and
he went to like Walmart going double
prints right and he gave me the prints
and I was flipping through them and I
was I was pretty taken aback by it I was
like this is amazing you know and it
kind of planted a seed in me it's about
two three months later I got an income
tax return check from whatever you know
job I had that last year and 200 bucks
so I called my brother up and I was like
dude I just got my income tax return
check I want to get a camera I said
which would you help me buy one and he
said yeah of course and so we went to a
pawn shop and 200 bucks I walked out
with this same camera heated because I
didn't want anything complicated I was
like this wouldn't make sense
so he tried to convince me actually to
get something else I got a Pentax k1000
fantastic camera and off I went but I
didn't really have any ambitions of
being a photographer right I didn't I
just wanted to go take pictures of funny
things that were happening in my life
and maybe stuff like skateboarding the
types of pictures I wanted to shoot were
pictures like this you know the crazy
friends I was hanging out with in my
life the people that you know I
skateboarded with and and and this guy
here my a friend of my he you know what
while he was asleep at night one of my
buddies went in and he just shaved his
head as a practical joke and he took it
in such great stride he like he wore the
haircut for like a week it was hilarious
and on that same camping trip you know
we were like jumping off cliffs and
cliff diving things and you know when I
look at this picture I don't remember my
friend like making this amazing dive off
the cliff all I remember is the belly
flop as he landed in the water in like
the exact same position reads like oh
and quickly I realized like wow you know
photography it's this cool time capsule
right
it gets the kind of you get to relive
memories and I remember I would after
trips you know I would all get prints
and we get to look at things and relive
them and I really fell in love
I almost won the lottery I had five
numbers I was one digit one number off
the winning number was 38
I had 39 so it's like really close right
and I had actually picked the numbers
which is the crazy big you know what it
is just randomly right you know that's a
memory that was like that was what I
wanted my camera for originally but I
started slowly taking it into the
mountains with me on my little like
weekend trips and after work and I
slowly started to kind of find a real
love and passion for it and I bought a
how to landscape photography book by
this guy John Shaw and this kind of
became my gospel you know I know it's
poor through this thing and learn like
technical aptitude and I quickly
realized that the camera was sort of a
new reason to go outside it really
started falling in love with the hunt
and I started looking at the map of
Colorado in a completely different way
and you know this is in Rocky Mountain
National Park I'd never been to Rocky
Mountain National Park and it was the
perfect reason like I'm gonna go spend
the weekend up there or find like some
new waterfall or go visit the sand dunes
you know isn't it was this new little
reason to go have different adventures I
found myself getting up early in the
morning to like chase sunrises and I was
finding this newfound motivation so I
was working at hewlett-packard at the
time I worked in IT and I made some
relationships with the people at the
imaging and printing division which is
in San Diego and I had this really great
situation where I was giving them photos
for free and they for them it was
actually probably better because they
weren't having to pay for these pictures
but what they were doing is they were
taking me use them using these landscape
pictures I had that trade shows and
you'd see them at like Best Buy where
they're like selling their new printers
and in exchange I was getting free
printer printers an unlimited ink and
paper so I was like scanning and
printing everything and just giving it
away to my friends and it was so much
fun right I just like this carte blanche
access and IV I had like so many
thirteen by night teens it's the biggest
you do and it was just like even if I
kind of like the photos like maybe it's
better big you know just print it out
this stuff is so fun having this this
access
you
[Music]